Britanny really came in and said wow
thank you Pearl for explaining to us how
men think you know she just was so
considerate and understanding and really
said I understand she said I prefer men
with eight figure bank accounts doesn't
mean they're going to talk to well you
know
um I think I'm gonna disagree with you
here because one honestly isn't that
hard to do I would say it is
exceptionally hard and damn near
impossible for a man to become a
multi-millionaire most men just aren't
going to do it however to become a
debt-free version we all start that way
everyone starts that way now most women
ruin it right but everybody starts as a
debt-free version with no tattoo